the biden administration reportedly
is rolling back a trump-era policy that
punished so-called sanctuary cities
which refused to cooperate with federal
immigration authorities raiders is
reporting those cities found in more
than two dozen states will no longer be
required
to work with immigrations and customs
enforcement
to get access to hundreds of millions of
dollars
in taxpayer money so kaylee i come to
you first on this because obviously
this happened uh during the last
administration
and this is another rollback of yet
another policy it didn't go well
uh with the border policies that joe
biden has rolled back
when you look at this one what do you
think will happen
well just another example here of a
completely
lawless and derelict immigration system
under president biden but we shouldn't
be surprised look
so much for sanctuary cities we're now
becoming a sanctuary
country and president biden made that
eminently clear that was his goal when
he
right out of the gate in january said
i'm issuing a 100-day moratorium on
deportations
only to be rebuked by a federal judge
who said no you can't do that but
nevertheless we discussed this a few
weeks back they're not arresting
illegal immigrants with criminal records
at the same rate as president trump
uh president trump you know in december
4 400 illegal immigrants with criminal
convictions were arrested compare that
to 1900
in march under biden so they're allowing
criminals to lawlessly take to our
streets gang members
in jails to be released without giving
the necessary information
to ice to lock up ms-13 gang members and
protect
innocent little beautiful girls like
kate steinle who should be here with us
today
were not for lawless immigration
policies
well and it is beyond those
heartbreaking facts and
and the losses of loved ones so on and
so forth with
those crimes being committed it's also
drug cartel members i mean when you talk
to attorneys general as far north from
the border as montana
what you learn is that they're seeing a
huge burst
in crime with the border situation as it
is now and if you begin to protect those
people
who are criminally infiltrating some of
our great cities across america they're
not here
to be part of america and follow a dream
as we all do and we know immigration
legal immigration has made us a great
country that's not why they came
they're here for completely opposite
reasons and if you loosen
the ability to go after those people do
you make america less
safe larry well again this is no
surprise the biden administration made
it very clear
that they felt the trump policies
towards a sanctuary cities was racist
and he was going to reverse it what i
find interesting is that the democrats
clearly have
determined that this is a positive
political calculus for them they feel
that eventually
illegal aliens turned voters will vote
for the democratic party
but they do this at the risk of
alienating black voters
the harvard economist named george
borjas has probably done more work on
the impact
of legal and illegal immigration than
maybe any other economist
and one of the big losers he says are
unskilled black and brown workers
working in the inner city
who have to compete for jobs that would
that are held by illegal aliens
who also put downward pressure on their
wages so the democrats have determined
that blacks either don't care don't know
or won't be able to figure out
the damage that unbridled unskilled
illegal immigration
does to them jenna your response to what
larry elder just said
well i again i come back to exactly what
it is that we're talking about here are
we talking about the funds that are now
being released to major cities
around the country uh a grant
specifically
in honor of an officer who was killed in
the line of duty
that is there to support the mental
health programs for
law enforcement to help with
prosecutions
to help in in community building so the
irony
of this very specific conversation about
funds being re-released to the cities
is that there's both the request from
parts of the left
to defund the police and then there's
the har from the right saying how could
this possibly be
and then here we are debating the fact
that president biden has released
resources to go specifically to law
enforcement
to support again everything from mental
health to prosecution so if you want to
talk about immigration let's have that
conversation
but this particular release of resources
is specifically to support law
enforcement
i want to come back to you larry and get
your rebuttal on that
well this is this is the broad
conversation that apparently she doesn't
want to have
the question is are we a nation of laws
or are we a nation
of lawlessness and there's no question
that this administration has made the
determination
as have people like alicia medina you
can go online and look at his 2009
uh speech where he said that if we can
get 11 million people
on a pathway to citizenship two out of
three will vote for us and we'll have
quote a governing coalition for the long
haul close quote
this is the calculation they've made
there's no question about that if it
were true that illegal aliens
turned voters uh turned citizens turned
voters would vote republican
we would not be having the conversation
any more than we'd be having a
conversation about d.c
statehood or puerto rican statehood we
would not be having this conversation
if this didn't politically benefit
democrats please admit that
larry i'll larry i'll specifically echo
exactly what kaylee said before you when
she said are we
a sanctuary country and i a friendly
reminder to
most folks that in fact this country has
served as a sanctuary for so many of our
ancestors
specifically for drug dealers not a
sanctuary and let me just say kaylee
we can't we you can't keep throwing down
ms-13 and just assuming you're making
broad sweeping statements
i'm not suggesting that the victims or
their or their strategies aren't real
but making
broad sweeping statements about the
people who are coming to this border
it's just it's an easy narrative
and larry's specifically related to the
lawlessness or lawful i drive the speed
limit
so then we're a country of laws let me
set this
up because i do want to clean something
up that you just said
i made it very clear who we were talking
about in terms of coming across that
border
no one on this panel has said it is the
majority a large number all
or anything like that what i said was
this country is as great as it is
because of the legal immigration that we
have seen and what we see is an
insurgency among
a few who come into our cities and go as
far
north as michigan as as montana and
other places when you talk to their
attorneys general they will tell you
that the crime is bursting as they are
coming across the border so i don't want
you to paint this
as kaylee or anybody else has has made
any you know suggestion even
that this is all people coming across
the border i mean
no one has said that no one believes
that exactly trust me we say
we believe same page we're on the same
page with that
i laid that out before anybody even
talked uh real quickly who wants to rap
emily yes please uh just respond to
jenna's comment so she's right this is
in in honor of a fallen officer and it
goes to fund a variety of
of initiatives that all are within law
enforcement right prosecutions
corrections
mental health drug programs and the like
so in 2020 that was about 253 million
dollars
and my point is that that's a complex
arena law enforcement means
law enforcement so a if you want a lot
and not exist then it needs to be
legislatively changed and b
the whole benefit there is to that
society and when you remove the
communication
between agencies when you reward
stopping that communication between
agencies then the suffering those are
the victims those are the members of the
community who don't benefit
from otherwise what would be an uptick
in actual
law enforcement and solving of crimes i
mean we literally just passed a bunch of
laws that go toward
upticks of encouraging communication
between agencies
that's how crimes are solved take it
from me as a criminal attorney
it really underscores the need for this
communication and so by rewarding that
it's not about
uh sort of pivoting to a question of
immigration on the southern border
it's pivoting or it's encompassing the
question of
actual communication between agencies in
the criminal sector
when you don't let federal agencies
communicate with local agencies
when they have um slips out for these
guys that have broken the law
then that's a whole different ball game
it's a whole different ballgame and it's
the community that suffers there